last night turned out to be a nightmare
for the new england patriots not
unexpected given everything that
happened to them beginning saturday when
we found out that cam newton tested
positive for covet 19 the game gets
delayed from sunday to monday they
travel
on monday once they get the all clear
that the virus hasn't spread or more
accurately
that the positives haven't happened yet
because of the incubation period there's
still a chance we're going to find out
today tomorrow thursday that there are
others who are positive that's the way
the virus works the way it worked last
night the chiefs
ultimately defeat the patriots 26 to 10
in a game that was a lot closer than
that for a lot longer and
but for the patriots committing the rare
act of beating themselves they could
have won the game
no doubt about it i mean let's let's
flush it out
i mean the first thing is i mean you sit
there
all right the first thought that went
through my head is whoa
what would this game look like if cam
newton was playing all right but let's
let's just talk about what we saw
last night first before i even dive into
all that stuff
i mean rare i mean two nights in a row
we saw two of the better coaches in
football
have a backup quarterback play and
really screw up the game like nick
mullens did for the 49ers and brian
hoyer did for the
for the new england patriots last night
i mean shocking some of the mistakes we
saw right mike shocking
you know horrible interception for a guy
that we know knows the offense
you know the the sack before half time
i mean that's about as bad as that that
gets
you know later on makes another mistake
i mean all of those type of things i
just was shocking to see a guy like
brian hoyer who had been in the new
england system for so long has played so
much football
and to your point i mean if he just
plays like average
they gotta they might win the football
game defense played great
they did all the right things on the
offensive side of the ball running the
ball
chewing the clock keeping the homes over
by the gatorade bottles and everything
like that
i mean really it was perfect execution
of a game plan
other than one guy and that one guy
messed it up for everybody else and of
course that is the
that is the reason they lost it is brian
hoyer his mistakes
the sacks he took everything like that
disaster
and it was amazing just at the moment
where
anyone watching the game started to
think maybe they should pull brian hoyer
they did for jared stidham and not that
jared stidham was dramatically better
and stidham
hadn't even been active in any of the
games all season long so he got thrown
into the fire
and it was too little too late by then
that hoyer chris webber moment at the
end of the first half was stunning
that's one of his strong suits right
he's been around year 14 he's smart he's
savvy he knows what's going on
situational awareness that's what bill
belichick preaches for him to think they
still had a timeout when he took that
sack
shocking means he didn't feel the
urgency to get rid of the ball
no right right sir bill belichick
talking about
quarterback play last night in that loss
to the chiefs
what went in the decision to start brian
hoyer over stidham tonight and
did you consider going to stinham
earlier though
yeah we do someone's best so that's what
we did
bill on the uh play just before half
time when uh brian took the sack
it looked like he signaled for a timeout
after he was taken down was there a
communication
issue there or do you know what happened
there
no we were out of timeouts it just it
looked like he was signaling for one so
was there a communication error in
getting him there
nope
how much consideration was there at half
time to uh to make the switch that you
made late in the third quarter
with a stidhum going in for hoyer
[Music]
not a lot he's just trying to play
better we're down by three points and
you don't miss some opportunities in the
first half so they're trying to
find ways to keep playing well
it was a three-point game
i kept waiting for the 22 second delay
remember when we got that one a couple
of weeks ago
and i love the double mess
uh he is look he's laying is he laying
it on thick or is he just being extra
what is it what is it you think what's
the fluorio take well
well well when he wears both masks
during the game and to the press
conference
when he's the first one we've seen all
year long wearing the mask
during the press conference and it's the
equivalent as i pointed out last night
on twitter of wearing underwear over
your cup
right it's the double whammy it really
is
odd to see it and yeah i think it's fair
to conclude that
that was his way of passive aggressively
reacting to the
conference call that he had to engage in
yesterday on
a day of a game i don't know probably
from the plane or once they land
they had the extended conference call
where they read everybody the riot act
and that's his reaction to having the
riot act read to him
if they're going to huff and puff he's
going to make sure he that no one blows
their house down and
if he can get a little subtle middle
finger in the process chris he's going
to do it yeah well maybe
yeah i don't doubt that with a guy like
bill belichick i don't i also don't
doubt that maybe he's just being really
really careful because he knows there
might be a potential outbreak on his
team
he is that smart to just go okay the
hell with this i'll put two masks on to
do it so
i know i thought the same thing as you
did i thought oh is he kind of just like
proving a point okay one mask might fall
off i'll wear two of them damn it and
show you
uh i i don't know but either way he's
got to be frustrated
i mean right that was a well and as to
as to what he said about hoyer
i mean he clearly screwed up hoyer
clearly screwed up and
it drives me crazy when a grown man
who's one of the smartest coaches who
has ever
stood on the sideline of a football
field acts like he didn't witness what
everyone else witnessed
or just chooses to ignore it like you
got to deal with it we know you're
dealing with it behind the scenes give
us an idea
show us something yeah right show us
something that would and this gets back
to the whole he
he's the opposite of bruce erin he's not
going to throw anybody under the bus
sometimes they need to be thrown under
the bus
sometimes it's fair to be thrown under
the bus brian hoyer deserves to be
thrown under the bus for making that
mistake
yeah 100 to sit there and act like you
don't know what they're talking about is
offensive to the intelligence of the
average person
if i were average i would have my
intelligence offended i'm somewhat below
average but if you if i had average
intelligence i'd be offended well yeah
i mean i i hear what you're saying like
brian hoyer yes i don't care if
whatever the circumstances he should
know the timeout situation
did new england say something to him
prior to that to go hey we're out of
timeouts i don't know i mean i think
that's probably what the report you need
to
no you're i'm i'm not i'm not making it
you're right he should not need to
he should not you know but there they
are
that debacle right they're going into
half and you're going
damn new england's got a chance to get a
field goal or maybe a touchdown and get
the ball in the second half and here we
go
because the chiefs look like they're in
trouble they're sleeping mahomes was off
i mean he should have been picked off
they were having a hard time finding
rhythm
staying on the field doing all those
things i mean three
i wonder why i wonder why i wonder why
he was having a hard time staying on the
field i wonder why he was having a hard
time finding a rhythm
bill belichick exactly no doubt that's
why he's got to be even more pissed off
yes it worked they had a game plan for
slowing down the chiefs and it worked
right and if our our quarterback who's
supposed to be smart isn't an idiot
we could win the game we win the game i
mean even after all that
it's six to three and there they go on
the second drive of the second half
right because they went three and out
pump the ball to kansas city they get
the ball back
and you go whoa it doesn't matter
they're going to go down the field here
and at least kick a field goal and the
game's going to be tied again
what's going to happen here and then he
thinks he's patrick mahomes and decides
to scramble around
and loses awareness of what's around him
with taco tarleton
who strips him and then of course we
know that just gave
kansas city a little momentum and it's
bam bam bam it's kelsey
boom touchdown and all sudden you're
like whoa what happened
so that's all of that all right
that's on the field hoyer mistakes
they're playing good
let alone the worst freaking call we've
seen in the nfl this year at the end of
the first half
are you kidding me with that crap that
was an interception
and at least a field goal for new
england was there sacking patrick
mahomes
there was no whistle there was nothing
about that
i was sitting there you know and you i
saw tony corenti run in there and act
like he was pointed down
and hold up the fist to say it's fourth
down that's why belichick never
challenged or did anything like that he
realized he was called down
but that that to me was another
huge moment and i'm blanking out because
they were already screwed over by the
refs a little earlier in the game at one
point and i'm forgetting about that
right here on this the heat of the
moment
but that was a huge game-changing type
call right there
by tony currenty and i i don't buy it i
mean that there was no whistle that was
way way late and i would like to see the
coaches soon was he messing with the
mask
maybe and trying to blow the whistle
dead i don't know
but either way that was bad luck for the
patriots
said karente to a pool reporter after
the game i felt that mahomes was being
controlled quite a bit prior to him
actually going to the ground and as he
was being controlled other players were
coming in at him and so with those
players
bearing down on him a quarterback is
considered in the grasp and his forward
progress is considered stopped
when i feel as though the player's
safety is being jeopardized that was the
case in this instance so rather than
allow him to get hit by a second and
third player
we shut it down and considered it
forward progress
that's a lot to understand and that's a
lot of different rules coming together
to justify the result he wasn't
in the grasp in control of anyone
and your forward progress is stopped
yeah what the hell is that when you're
in the backfield trying to buy
time to throw you may you may have
backward progress
it's patrick mahomes for crying out loud
he wasn't trying to gain yardage he was
trying to keep the play alive forward
progress doesn't mean jack diddley you
know what
when you're in the pocket trying to
extend a play it's ridiculous
we would have been robbed the greatest
moment in nfl history
if forward progress of eli manning was
stopped against the patriots in super
bowl
42. i bet bill belichick wishes they had
called his forward progress stopped then
yeah it's just one of those things where
when you see it it contradicts
everything that you've come to expect
and know about football
he wasn't down that play wasn't over he
wasn't in the grasp
forward progress wasn't stopped and you
wonder
how many other quarterbacks not named
patrick mahoney i agree but i've ever
gotten that consideration
i agree with that listen that's the
first thing that that to me was the
first time
ever i went ooh that was a patrick
mahomes kansas city call
it's the first time i think i ever saw
it where i went that was a referee
who likes my homes knows how awesome he
is mahomes is probably polite to the
refs like he seems to be polite to
everybody
and the charm worked whatever whatever
you want to say
yeah but i yeah yeah i don't know but
either way it was that's this isn't this
is no no
this isn't patrick holmes is a nice guy
this isn't
he says hello to us when he sees us on
the field
this isn't i like him this isn't he's on
my fantasy team
this is potentially and and this is why
when the league makes it known on the
sunday of week two that they've
previously instructed the officials to
only call clear and obvious fouls
it opens a box full of pandora as you
would say she's in there
she's in there um to speculate on what
else the officials have been told
about general concepts or specific
players because patrick mahomes is the
cash cow
this year patrick holmes is the straw
that's stirring the nfl's drink
patrick holmes is one of the reasons why
millions are going to tune in
and watch any game you think last
night's ratings are going to suffer
because cam newton didn't play
hell no because patrick holmes did play
so you'll wonder during those
conversations they're never going to
tell us about
that happen all the time have the
officials been told
to protect quarterbacks specifically to
protect patrick mahomes i think that's
fair
for us to wonder about it because this
is a year where
they're just trying to hold it all
together that's right they're trying to
hold the audience together there was a
memo that went out yesterday to the
teams telling them
don't freak out about the ratings the
ratings are going to be what they are in
an election year but you know what the
nfl's got to be a little freaked out
about the ratings and they can't have
the ratings implode
because the best player in football
can't play
that's why the patriots got screwed last
night in that moment
yeah in my opinion yeah i mean i i don't
i don't doubt that
i mean i i don't know if i'm gonna buy
like everything you said there that
there was a meeting and you know there
was something
said to them that way but i do believe
that
you know okay well yeah something about
the quarterbacks protecting the star
players that way
you know and yes some things don't even
have to be said no they really don't
that's where i was going with it mike
that's exactly right they just don't
need to be said
he's the crown jewel of the league
you're exactly right just like brady was
five years ago and if somebody blew
in his ear they were like don't you do
that you're not allowed to blow in his
ear that's only for gisele
she can only blow in his ear but yes
that was a huge moment and i can't
forget i mean new england got screwed
over by another call early in the game
where bill got pissed off and i can't
remember what that is and i'm gonna have
to wait till commercial break or
whatever
to remember it but either way back to
your point
new england's game plan and approach to
the game
was brilliant it really was and again we
saw
a lot of creative defenses from new
england
that you don't see from anybody else
they're playing man-to-man coverage on
hill
and tyree kill and travis kelsey and
then they got the other four d
four dbs playing quarters coverage and
doing stuff that just nobody else in
football does that's just bill
and outside the box thinking now can we
go to the fun part
you ready for the fun part what would
that game look like if freaking superman
was in there
what would it look like because let's
put a pin on that okay let's put a pin
on it go there okay
yeah let's let's let's talk a little bit
more about
what what what do we if if if cam newton
is superman what is mahomes
is he batman no well yeah what is he
i don't know he's he's he's greater than
that right now he's some sort of avenger
uh that is just indestructible and i'm
not sure if i know enough to who that is
is he thanos i know he can't beat that
he's too nice and a good guy we can't
let him beat thanos
all right here's patrick holmes talking
about a night that was
more difficult and challenging than he
probably expected against the patriots
obviously i didn't i didn't do enough
because we didn't execute at a high
enough level and i wasn't able to find
the guys
i didn't play very good football but uh
i thought i did whatever i could to try
to stay in tune with the game and
hopefully if this presents itself again
which hopefully it doesn't um
i'll be able to do better
yeah hey look you're not gonna throw for
five touchdown passes and 400 yards
every game you're not going to have
no a no-look pass behind the back pass
not every game is going to be a patrick
mahomes game and what makes the chief so
amazing is they still find a way to win
the games that aren't the patrick that's
right
by 16 points that's how good the rest of
the team is no chris jones no big deal
of course again it helps that the
patriots kind of imploded a little bit
with brian hoyer
but still when you can still win
when you're far from having your best
night
that means you're special yes right and
that means watch out
everybody no exactly we saw that last
year
you know that's you're right and then
this year i think it's even more
apparent where it's just
they have such self-confidence and
belief that they cannot be defeated and
that they're just gonna answer the bell
whenever they need to it's
it's scary that way and yeah they were a
little asleep at the wheel last night
definitely i mean that's about as off of
i've seen
mahomes in a while in the first half
you know not only like hey a few dumb
mistakes
mccourty should have had the
interception but there was a few throws
that just came out of his hand funny too
or you're like ah
my home's usually you know stripes that
in there just throws it right in yeah
there wasn't a lot of room so
he was off of his game i do and
you know too i just wonder and i don't
even mean to go here but this is just my
natural thought mike because i know we
put the pin in it but i wonder the fact
of cam newton not being out there how
much that affected the kansas city
chiefs you know we talk about the effect
of
what cam newton might be for new england
but what cam newton does too
is he wakes the other damn team up too
whether that's in preparation
or when you see him come out for
warm-ups and you go
what who is that person playing
quarterback
i mean and and then he starts talking
crap and puffing out his chest
and it adds to the intensity of the game
overall
so not only would the patriots be better
with cam newton i do believe that
the chiefs would have been better last
night too if he's playing they're going
to rise to the challenge cam's going to
needle them and let them know when he
runs for six yards and everything like
that and that's what
is great about watching cam newton
football he's one of the best about
pissing the other team off
and adding to the intensity but uh i i i
it's a point we made last tuesday chris
it's
the point we made last tuesday when you
get the fully
focused and motivated chiefs you better
watch
exactly when you get them when they're
just kind of like man and then
they go to overtime with the chargers
and win the game and get out of there i
mean ravens chiefs last week
what did i say ravens chiefs last week
when when that happened
it's like hey okay chiefs are ready yes
you know patrick mahomes is counting out
the four i mean everything's locked in
it's lamar jackson to your point
last night you take cam newton off the
field and the chiefs kind of
i'm not going to say not show up but the
full boar 100 percent
pedal to metal chiefs aren't there right
let me ask you this about
what happened as well yeah because i saw
the tweets yesterday everybody propping
up brian hoyer he knows the offense
inside and out he's respected he'll do
fine well he didn't
yeah no first of all but second of all
the other 10 guys on offense spent all
week
with the cam newton portion of the plate
that's right too
getting ready for that right so they had
what
two days and maybe they who knows what
they did
they probably couldn't go do a walk for
on sunday because they were freaked out
about the virus had virtual meetings on
sunday
that's right how do you even practice
the the portion of the playbook
for hoyer because there isn't a whole
lot of overlap
no between the hoyer playbook and the
newton playbook and they just had to go
do it
you're right now they were they were
handicapped in this in this effort
there's no there's no question
you're right you're preparing for cam
newton what we're going to do with him
at quarterback
all the mesh points stuff with him and
the shotgun here's the run plays here's
the speed sweep the fake speed sweep all
of those things
that goes out the door with brian hoyer
it holds no water
with a guy like him kansas city doesn't
give a damn if brian hoyer's faking the
read option or out on the edge
that means nothing to them so that that
effect you're right
was totally lost a huge part of the
patriots game plan
and there that's why they had to kind of
just go to like all right here's
traditional run plays right here's a
fullback here's a tailback hand the ball
off pulling guard
and then they kind of got into all right
when we want to throw the ball
it's not going to really be the cam
newton pass offense either we're going
to
revert back to basic brady pass offense
because hoyer knows that
and work that and they're not built for
that right now that
they're not that kind of team and they
don't have the kind of weapons too for a
guy like brian hoyer
to really work with you know cam newton
can make weapons better because he
will hang in the pocket he's got a laser
right arm
so he's very aggressive that way and
then of course what he does with his
movement and extending place and all
that
is you know he makes everybody else
around him better hoyer needs help
to make him look better and this was not
the right match last night as we saw the
the
pressure was on him at certain points
and he folded and didn't do well
in those areas and one of the reasons
the flip back to the old offense wasn't
as as bad as it could have been for the
patriots
the chiefs prepared yeah no
question for superman right right no not
for jimmy olsen
and and so they had to change up their
approach on the fly too
what they would have done last week
because or the cam newton we got to stop
cam newton and
stuff they used against the ravens
carries over and and now all of a sudden
same idea just flip side of it oh crap
they're going to run a completely
different offense and we have to
readjust oh and we don't have chris
jones and i think that's why
the the strip down scale down flip it
over to the brian hoyer portion of the
playbook
worked to a certain extent i do because
the chiefs weren't ready for it either
yeah i think there is certainly
something to that i bet you there was
some things in formations where he
dropped back and they were like just
damn we didn't expect them to do that
they
they haven't done that this year with
you know cam newton or whatever that is
so i
i bet it did throw a curveball to spags
and everything like that
and you know him trying to figure out
how they're going to attack him and all
those type of things but
that's what i was so excited about to
see the match up with spags versus josh
mcdaniels as you heard romo and nance
talking about that great matchup
and they just came off a win off of
defending you know the baltimore ravens
and lamar jackson like you mentioned and
here was cam newton who runs a similar
type of offense but is a different type
of player than lamar and all that i was
just
very excited that and really ultimately
mike
we'll see where new england ends up i
mean i think you and i both think
they're a good football team they got
some tough
damn schedule but this could play in
their favor if they meet up with kansas
city again they really can this is the
kind of game where
you know they're going to walk away and
if they do play them again they're going
to go we mess that up
we're as good as that team and we didn't
have our best player that day
so they're going to be able to go into
the next matchup with like kind of chest
out going yeah we know it's my homes we
respect it
but we think we could play with you guys
and beat you and i don't think they're
going to be
one bit feared uh or fear uh kansas city
at all and they're one of the few teams
i think in the afc that probably won't
fear kansas city as we
if you get to the playoffs and the flip
side of that's also true there may be
some doubt that creeps into the chiefs
if and when the patriots come back to
town with cam newton
the patriots are hopeful cam newton will
be able to play this weekend against the
broncos
if he's not cleared who plays
quarterback they got to go to jared
sidham it's almost the exact same story
as sunday night i just can't imagine
kyle shanahan going back to nick mullins
because
the team's gonna watch the film today
and maybe on the plane ride back last
night and they're gonna see the game and
they're just gonna oh man there's just
gonna be no denying it they're gonna
walk away and go
we lost the game because of brian hoyer
holy cow he played like crap
the players are gonna say that the
coaches of course are gonna be saying
that
and i would be shocked if it's not jared
stidham i don't know why it wasn't
really jared stood him from the start to
me that was one of the lost stories
of the week and kind of where that whole
thing happened and played out i know he
got injured during training camp
and that affected reps and things like
that and i don't know if that's where he
lost the stronghold of being the backup
and they just didn't feel comfortable
but i don't think there's any way they
go back to hoyer this week if cam can't
go
i think it was yesterday chris that i
was just having
trouble processing the fact that tom
brady isn't on the patriots anymore was
that yesterday yeah and i kept referring
to brady the patriots
let me tell you what happened yeah
watching the game last night at some
point in the first half
jim nance makes reference to the fact
that the patriots play the broncos this
week
and i i was eating dinner with my wife
or something don't even tell me
they already played the broncos they
already played the broncos
what is he thinking i already played the
broncos and it took me like 45 seconds
to finally realize tom brady played the
broncos were you going not the president
where are you going
tom brady and the patriots they have a
hard time playing the broncos in denver
you say that yeah i'm thinking they
already played the broncos that's
already happened
it's all what is he talking about oh oh
yeah
tom brady's not on the patriots anymore
they probably wish they would have had
tom brady last night
uh if they'd had tom brady they'd have
won last night they would correct
there's no doubt
yes there's no doubt yes that game was
there for the taking
they like we like we talked about the
game plan on the offense and defensive
side of the ball
was perfect and it was executed
perfectly
by just about everybody except the one
damn guy who's got the ball in his hand
more than everybody
else he had a crappy day
remember last year at this time we were
talking about how great this patriots
defense is some people were even
whispering
in guarded terms 85 bears that's how
dominant they were
where's the defense this year compared
to last year i don't know if it's as
dominant as last year especially up
front
i think the secondary is still every bit
as good but i don't know if they have
quite the size and
you know versatility they have uh in the
front seven like they did last year you
know hightower van noy jamie collins i
mean yes
there's a difference there but i still
think this is one of the better defenses
in football i do
and i think more importantly because of
the secondary and it's
it's so elite it really is they match up
better with kansas city maybe than any
other team in
football and that's what's scary it
gives it gives them great flexibility
even when they have to play a team like
baltimore
because they can put so much on that
secondary and then they go hey everybody
else
stop a run game whatever that is but
it's still really damn good i just don't
know if i'm gonna say it's as good as
last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports